top five paying sales jobs you might not  have heard of so number one is you can  look at selling solar some of these best  solar guys make two three four hundred  thousand dollars a year just going  door-to-door selling solar panels number  two is selling pest control a lot of  those guys can make 200 300 400 000 a  year selling pest control same thing  with alarm systems and the reason is  because these have huge packages and  long lifetime values the fourth one is  you can sell high ticket stuff so in  general the higher the ticket of the  thing that you're selling the more money  you get paid and here's the beautiful  thing it takes the same amount of time  to sell something for a million bucks as  it takes to sell something for 100 bucks  and it's just the question of what kind  of beliefs you have as a salesman  whether or not you can do it but sales  is sales and so if you are going to be  selling you might as well sell the most  expensive stuff